يقول خبراء جيدون إن الاقتصاد اللبناني
قد تصاعد إلى أسوأ أزمة له منذ
الحرب الأهلية التي أنهت في عام 1990
الدين الحكومي وحشًا حوالي 150 في
المائة من الناتج المحلي الإجمالي السنوي وهو ثالث أعلى معدل
في العالم ، وقد ارتفعت تكلفة الاقتراض
إلى عائد السندات لمدة عامين
قفز إلى  أكثر من 30 في المائة من
قيمة الليرة اللبنانية مرتبطة
بالدولار ، لكن الحكومة يمكن أن
تتعرض لضغوط لخفض قيمتها ، لقد
جعلنا مجتمعنا يشغل منصب
وزير الاقتصاد والتجارة في لبنان ،
كما شغل منصب نائب محافظ البنك المركزي
الذي انضم إليه.  أنا الآن من دبي ، شكراً
جزيلاً لك سيدي على انضمامك إلينا ، من
الجيد حقًا أن تكون لديك في العرض ، والنظر
إلى مستويات الديون هذه بالنظر إلى حقيقة
أنك تنظر إلى هذه النظرة من البنوك القريبة جدًا
مما يخلق حالة من الذعر ومحافظ البنك المركزي في
وقت سابق من هذا الأسبوع  لـ CNN
كانت أيامًا تفصلنا عن الانهيار الاقتصادي ،
هذه هي الرسائل الصحيحة التي يجب إرسالها
في هذا الوقت عندما يكون الاقتصاد على
حافة الهاوية ، فإن النقطة الآن هي
استعادة  الثقة والثقة كما كان بن ريد
عمان يتحدث ، تحتاج إلى
إرسال الرسائل الصحيحة ويحتاج البنك المركزي
إلى توسيع السيولة للنظام المصرفي
في هذا الوقت
لم يغرس إغلاق البنوك خلال الأسبوعين الماضيين
الثقة وهذا هو السبب في أن الناس
سوف تسحب النقود ، هناك الآن
ضوابط غير رسمية على رأس المال ، هناك
سوق موازية أو سوق سوداء وعملات
أجنبية ، ما يجب أن يحدث
الآن هو في الحقيقة إجراءات بناء الثقة ،
ولا سيما تشكيل حكومة جديدة من
شأنها تصحيح
المسار الذي نسير فيه.  أنه عندما تذكر
الأسواق السوداء من حيث
العملة ، فإننا نرى ذلك دائمًا في الاقتصادات
التي تربط الدولار وتحصل على ربط
عملتها بالدولار الأمريكي
لأنها في الأساس ليست قيمة حقيقية
من حيث ما تراه
الأرض إذا ما تحملت الحكومة اللبنانية
الألم الآن ، فلا بأس من خفض القيمة
بدلاً من خفض
احتياطياتها من العملات الأجنبية ، الأمر الذي يضع البلاد
وأكثر  صعوبة فردية
لا أعتقد أنه من الحكمة أن تقوم بالتثبيت
الآن ما تحتاج إلى القيام به
هو إجراء إصلاحات هيكلية للإصلاح المالي
، وبعد ذلك يمكنك إعادة
النظر في الربط إذا كنت مجرد بيضة عميقة الآن ، فهذا
يخاطر بأن 140 في المائة من
الدين الحكومي  بالعملة الأجنبية ،
لدى البنوك نفسها جزءًا أجنبيًا
من التزامات العملة كما يفعل
قطاع الشركات وهذا يعني أن
الحكومة نفسها ربما لن تكون
قادرة على تمويل مصلحتها
وديونها الخارجية ، لذا ما تريد القيام به هو
إجراء التعديل في  مناطق أخرى
ثم إعادة النظر في الربط ، حسنًا ،
لكنك تتحدث عن توفير
السيولة للبنوك ، هل
تمتلك الحكومة اللبنانية المال
لتتمكن من القيام بذلك ، وإذا لم يكن
الأمر كذلك ، فيمكنها الحصول عليها من لا ، يجب أن يكون
يقوم به البنك المركزي عندما تربط
عملتك بالدولار كما هو
الحال في لبنان ، عليك استخدام
احتياطياتك الدولية.
لدى المرضى القدرة
ولكن ذلك محدود في الوقت
وأعتقد أن هذه هي اللحظة التي تعلمون فيها أنني
أريد أن أبدأ في التفكير ربما في
برنامج صندوق النقد الدولي وصندوق الاستقرار
وسلسلة من الإجراءات الإصلاحية للبنان